>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND JAMES COMEY ACCUSING EACH
OTHER OF LYING OVER "SPYGATE."
THAT IS WHAT TRUMP CALLED
REPORTS THAT THE F.B.I. HAD AN
INFORMANT IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
COMEY TWEETED TODAY ATTACKS ON
THE F.B.I. AND LYING ABOUT
WORK WILL DO LASTING DAMAGE TO
OUR COUNTRY.
TRUMP RESPONDED BY SUGGESTING
THAT COMEY SHOULD WORRY ABOUT
THE UPCOMING I.G. REPORT.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE DID,
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE
LAWS, THE TREMENDOUS LIES --
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LIES, THE
TREMENDOUS LIES, ALL THAT IS
GOING ON, JAMES COMEY HAS A
LOT OF PROBLEMS NOW.
>> Laura: AMONG THE PROBLEMS
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT FROM
THE DAILY CALLER THE RANK AND
FILE F.B.I. AGENTS WANT TO
TESTIFY TO CONGRESS THAT
POLITICS AND INCOMPETENCE AT
THE TOP ARE DESTROYING THE
BUREAU.
LET'S DISCUSS THAT WITH
SENATOR RON JOHNSON, CHAIRMAN
OF THE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE WHO RECENTLY SENT A
LETTER TO F.B.I. DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY REQUESTING
INFORMATION ON COMEY'S
BRIEFING OF TRUMP ON THAT
INFAMOUS RUSSIA DOSSIER.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU IN THE
STUDIO.
>> HELLO, LAURA.
>> Laura: TELL US.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
THREADS IT'S HARD TO UNPACK.
TRY TO KEEP IT SIMPLE.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF SMOKE.
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
THIS IS LIKE 1,000-PIECE
JIGSAW PUZZLE.
MILLER PROBABLY HAS A FEW
HUNDRED PIECES.
I.IG HOROWITZ HAS A FEW LESS.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE POWER AND
HE CAN'T BRING IN WITNESSES
OUTSIDE THE GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESS HAS MORE PIECES THAN
THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
>> Laura: THEY'RE GETTING A
LOT OF LEAKS.
SELECTIVE LEAKS.
>> PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT ARE THOSE LEAKERS TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH?
TRYING TO GET AHEAD BEFORE THE
PUBLIC HAS THE TRUTH.
THIS ENTIRE INVESTIGATION IS
BACKWARDS.
THIS IS A POLITICAL
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK CONGRESS OUGHT TO GET
THE INFORMATION FIRST.
WRITE THE REPORTS AND THEN IF
WE SEE THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
REFER IT TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OR A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THE PROBLEM IS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR CONGRESS TO GET
ANY INFORMATION WHATSOEVER.
WE HAVE SOME INFORMATION.
I'M TRYING TO LAY IT OUT IN
TIMELINES.
CHUCK GRASSLEY TALKING ABOUT
THE RECENT TWEET THAT IS
GETTING PROMINENCE.
ON AUGUST 5, THE WHITE HOUSE
IS RUNNING THIS.
COMBINE THIS WITH THE TWEET WE
GOT IN A LOT OF TROUBLE FOR
PUBLISHING IN ONE OF OUR
REPORTS
>> Laura.
PUT IT UP SO PEOPLE CAN SEE
IT.
A QUOTE FROM GRASSLEY TO
ROSENSTEIN TODAY IN A LETTER
AND SAID AS ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
TEXT FROM LISA PAIGE AND PETER
STROZK THEY WANT ALL THE
TEXTS.
ONE EXAMPLE AN OFFICIAL'S NAME
WAS REDACTED IN REFERENCE TO A
TEXT ABOUT THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE RUNNING AN
INVESTIGATION.
ALTHOUGH IT'S UNCLEAR WHO THIS
INVESTIGATION THEY WERE
REFERRING.
GOING BACK TO MY QUESTION IN
THE ANGLE, WHO KNEW ABOUT
THIS?
>> WE HAVE SO MANY REDACTIONS
WE CAN'T PUT PIECES TOGETHER.
THERE IS A LOT OF SMOKE.
IF YOU COMBINE THAT WITH THE
TWEET WE PUBLISHED ID JUST GOT
BASHED FOR IN THE PRESS A
MONTH LATER.
SEPTEMBER 2.
POTUS WANTS -- THIS IS FROM
PAIGE TO STRONG -- PAGE TO
STROZK.
POTUS WANTS TO KNOW EVERYTHING
WE ARE DOING.
THIS IS AFTER THEY CLOSED UP,
EXONERATED HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT IS WHAT WE WILL GET AN
I.G. REPORT ON.
HOROWITZ DID AN EXCELLENT JOB.
McCABE GOT HIM, CAUGHT HIM
LYING AND LAID OUT 32 PAGES
EXACTLY WHY THE DEPUTY AND THE
ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE F.B.I.
LIED TO THE F.B.I.
OKAY?
I MEAN, IF ANYBODY OUGHT TO
KNOW THAT IS A CRIME, THAT IS
THE MAN WHO SHOULD HAVE DONE
SO.
IT'S NO LONGER MARTYR
McCABE.
THESE TYPE OF THE TEXTS HERE
ARE UNBELIEVABLY REVEALING.
>> Laura: THE QUESTION I
ASKED IN MY OPENING ANGLE, WHO
BASICALLY KNEW HOW THIS WAS
GOING DOWN?
CARTER PAIGE IS THE REASON YOU
ARE OPENING UP A BIG
INVESTIGATION WHERE YOU END UP
PUTTING AN INFORMANT OUT
THERE?
AND THEN YOU ENUP SURVEILLING
THE TRUMP TOWER AND CUSHION
CUSHION AND THE GUYS TO GET
THE PHONE CALLS LISTENED TO?
THEN YOU HAVE A RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE VISITED BY THE
F.B.I.
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET HIM TO
AGREE TO -- THIS IS A
COLLUSION THING GOING ON.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR --
C'MON, HELP US WITH THE
COLLUSION STUFF.
EVEN THE RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE
WHO HATES PAUL MANAFORT, THE
OLLIE -- OLIGARCH SAYS I CAN'T
STAND HIM BUT THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH
IMAGINATION TO LOOK AT THIS
AND SAY THIS IS A SETUP.
THE WHITE HOUSE RUNNING THIS
AND POTUS WANTS TO KNOW
EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING.
THE HATS START PUTTING TWO AND
TWO TOGETHER.
WE MAYBE GOT 25 TO 50 PIECES
OUT OF THAT 1,000 PAGE --
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOOD AT
JIGSAW PUZZLES?
ARE YOU GOOD AT IT?
>> I GET FRUSTRATED.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE WAITING FOR
THE I.G. REPORT ON THE CLINTON
E-MAIL.
HOPEFULLY THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
THAT HAS BEEN OUR
INVESTIGATION.
THREE YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET THIS
INFORMATION.
WE'LL GET THAT.
BUT WE ARE ON THE CASE.
I'M WRITING TO CHRISTOPHER
WRAY.
WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR
DOCUMENT PRODUCTION?
WHO IS DOING THE REDACTION?
WHAT IS THE CRITERIA?
WHAT WAS IT?
WHAT IS IT NOW?
WE CAN'T EVEN GET THAT
INFORMATION.
>> Laura: HOW DO YOU YOUR
OVERSIGHT?
IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO BE THAT
IT IS THIS TAFFY PULL.
I KNOW THERE IS ALWAYS
HISTORIC TENSION AMONG THE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE TO SHOW
EVERYTHING.
I DON'T EVER REMEMBER IT BEING
THIS BAD.
I DON'T.
>> WHAT SURPRISED ME IS WE
HAVEN'T HAD F.B.I. AGENTS COME
FORWARD TO THE COMMITTEE.
THEY WILL GO TO THE PRESS --
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO
TESTIFY ON WHAT, SENATOR?
>> WELL, WE HEARD THAT WHEN
COMEY EXONERATED CLINTON THAT
THEY ACTUALLY WANTED TO, THEY
WERE GOING TO BLOW A GASKET
BASICALLY.
WHY DIDN'T THEY COME FORWARD?
COME FORWARD TO MY COMMITTEE.
WE WILL PROTECT YOU.
>> Laura: YOU SHOULD BRING
THE RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE IN,
GET HIM ON VIDEO.
GET THE RUSSIAN LAWYER.
GET VESELNITSKAYA.
THEY DIDN'T TALK TO HER.
>> IT WOULD NICE TO HAVE MORE
EVIDENCE BEFORE DOING THE